好,谢谢大家参加会议,上一周的话,其实我觉得不光是上一周吧,就从春节过完到现在这三周,其实市场就是我们能说的市场的观点和整个市场的趋势,其实都是在等待川普上台,川普昨天上台。
我说一下他上台前后的一些操作,最近那个特别是避权市场,大家看的还是非常惊心动魄的,那么还有就是他上台之后一些政策会怎么样,那么首先呢,我还是坚持我之前的观点,就是美国经济其实是非常强硬的,它不光是,它是两方面,我们认为这个温度是好,就是它两方面,第一个呢,就是它经济增长基本面是非常强的,第二呢,就是它的这个通胀,
通胀因为本身是一个非常质厚的因素,那么在短期里面,特别是这两个季度,我不觉得它本身会出来通胀,那么所有的东西其实都是连带的,
就说可能是被政策连带,或者是特朗普关税政策导致,或者是他移民政策导致,所以在加入辩量之前,就我们又回到我们三周前讲这个事情,就是我们现在在base case,那么这个base case呢,就是美国经济比较强的增长,通胀相对来说比较温和。
那么在最近的这些经济数据都一次一次在验证这个事情,那么记得我上周讲的时候,大家可能还是来比较担心星期三的通胀会怎么样,那确实星期三的通胀不怎么样,就是这个callcpi是低于预期,其实其实我们说啥是正好meet预期和预期一致,那么这个通胀数据跟预期一致,
那么经济增长数据是大幅好于预期在周五的时候,其实这个是本身是给到市场应该是一个很强的网上的动力。
那么我记得我上周还讲过利率的定价是有点过分了,那利率就回调了,就是从4.8的这个水平回调下来,因为大家没有那么担心美国可能会加弃啊,或者是美国这个将近今年不降级啊。
那么在base case里面,我们的就每次讲一下base case吧,在base case里面美国的这个状态还是会就是维持在一个比较就经济比较好,然后通胀相对来说比较低,美联储可以去观察市场怎么样,然后再做再做行动。
那么联储在base case情况下呢,可能今年就是这样降一次到两次利息。
10年期的利率,那么我去年是10年期利率的大空头,我觉得发行会导致10年期利率像西西福斯推石头一样,10年期的债像西西福斯推石头一样,一直往上推一直往下掉。
那么今年这个力量呢,并没有那么强,我记得我上周也讲过供应量。
那么到年底的话,我觉得这个数据会在哪呢,就是10年期一个比较合理的交易范围,在4.3到4.5。
这个是我个人的观点,那么也就是说一月份已经往上,利率往上突破了这个区间,你不要去期望哪怕去降两次息,
因为我的降息的预期可能会比市场要多一点,我对通胀更看好,我对美国经济也更看好。
那么在这种情况,即使他pricing两次降息,10年期下不来,这个才是他供应导致的问题,不会不太会再上去。
需要10年期再上到5%,他背后需要的这个经济的强度,列度和后面需要的通胀的这个拉动力,那么现在在市场上并不存在。
你们可以去看一下美国这个比较长趋势的这个job opening,就是这个就业岗位。
还有呢,就是他的这个wage cost,就是那个人工的成本,那这两个是高盛的图啊,就是这个当然花的时间比较长。
那么我们会看到经济数据本身是有很大幅度的上下的这个波动的,但是你把这个波动综合起来,最后的预期它其实并没有变化那么大,就好像那个能房陪路。
你可以说飞龙就业,你可以说飞龙就业24万,是一个一下子往上波动很大数据,这里没有飞龙就业。
那么但是呢,它还是符合着在25万到20万的,到15万到18万20万吧,我认为中中卫数就在18万,那么这个区间里面。
所以他在疫情之后很明显看到很多数据,他的波动会变得更大,但是呢,他本质上的这个趋势,我觉得还是没有变化。
所以先总结一下这个基本面,那基本的我们认为大概率按照现在的轨迹走下去,就是就是这么一个情况。
那么现在轨迹走下去,那美国会怎么美国资产会怎么样的,我觉得美国资产相对来说还是会涨,那这个我在三周其实讲的话都差不多。
美国资产还是会继续涨,然后对于美国资产势力好,但是呢,今年的波动会变得更大,为什么?
因为这个东西的预期也比去年高,经济好,通常地的预期比去年高,那个比前年也要高,然后前年还是有很大的分歧的。
那在AI带动的时候有很大分歧,然后那个因为预期更高,所以市场即使是一个在实现预期的过程中,因为我实现,真的实现,他还是要涨。
那么但是在实现预期过程中,他波动很大,最终的程度没有去年大,也没有前年大。
那这就是我觉得Basecase对美国的一个定位,就是还是个纽士,是会有很大的波动。
那回来说一下我们的特朗普同志,那么美元的话,你可以看到在这个基础上,美元其实走了很强,那这个强度到什么程度,这个是我们在广场协议之后基本上没有看到过的。
这样的一个强度,就是说美元走势非常强,这个背后代表着美国对于欧洲对于日本的代表者和差别。
那我跟我们上次讲的一样,那么现在市场上最大的对外汇,其实也怕外汇影响到那个风险市场,股票,比特币啊。
所以我上个周被问到最大的两个问题,就是美元这个强度能不能是不是pricing,能不能因为特朗普不希望强美元吗?
所以能不能因为特朗普的政策会被改变,这是一。
第二呢,在短期里面,因为下周这周那个BLG,就日本央行要开会,日本可能会生息,我觉得大概率日本确实是会生息的。
那么日本会生息,那么这个东西会对美元的这个走强有没有一个负担带动效应?
那我觉得这两个问题,其实还有第三个我自己说的就是特朗普的关税政策如果出来比较慢,那么对于短期里面美元会不会有压力?
我觉得三是会有的,而且昨天其实已经看到了,特朗普没有在入侄白宫的第一时间马上推出他的关税政策,特别是没有对中国马上推出。
这个呢让人民币上涨了,让美元就是美元强势掉了一个头,毕竟他短期涨了太多了。
那么BLG还有就是Trump这些政策对美元走强会有多大影响?
我觉得不太会。首先BLG这个政策,BLG是我觉得大概率日本要降息的,因为他第一个他不太能容忍通脏进一步恶化,然后事后再去补救。
他上一次没降,更多的是要更加明确美国的关税政策,特朗普的政策或者是特朗普执政团队的一些态度最后要出来,这个是需要一段时间沟通的。
那么,但现在这个情况下呢,他不降的风险会比降要更大一点。
所以我觉得他降,他不降说错了,BLG升息要Hike,他不升息的风险比升息要更大一点。
所以呢,他1月份Hike到0.5的概率我觉得还是很大的。
所以这个,这个是我个人判断,但是市场上widely expect,所有人都觉得他1月份要升息。
那之前我就是他1月份要升,然后那个现在,很多人说他12月份要升,现在拖到了1月份,他其实是拖不下去了。
所以这个呢,被市场定下基本上定到了,他那个升息的概率还是很大。
甚至你可以看日本的JGB的利率10年,像高盛预期JGB利率10年在2025年要升到1.6。
就是背后一方面,是他那个BLG要去升息。
第二方面是tempremium要上升,那tempremium上升的原因就是通脏预期要上升。
所以日本也是个标准的,就是货币政策在追赶他的经济增长和追赶他的这个通脏的责任国家。
那么日远会不会对美元走强呢?那不太会。
就是当然了,欧元对美元是更明确的要走弱,日远走强我觉得也很难,
因为毕竟这两国家的divergence,就是日本和美国也有divergence,美国的经济太好,
所以他经济的基本面强度更强,所以这一轮带动是,当然了,短期里面带动是美国利率带动,
选个外汇都是美国利率带动。
但是更长一年里面,我虽然觉得利率可能会回到4.3到4.5的水平,
就是这个是我觉得十年期的一个中间化的固执,但是将不下去,
或者是连组基本上的派对还是相对来说比较强硬的。
日本就算是升息,那美元有个dex,大家会去交易美元利率吗?
那么美元利率在很多程度上定价还没有完成,这我觉得是很重要的原因,
因为这个basket中间还有CNH,那么CNH是一个完全被操控的,
就是完全政府监管的这个汇率,
现在那个中央银行,中国人民银行已经告诉香港说你们要同一万里,
然后让香港去把那个CNH收回来,把香港的话会储备换成CNH,
比如说中央还是很缺钱了,把香港的钱给用上,那么在这种情况下,
他前两周上企的手到7.3还是挺有压力的,那么特朗普的政策最后对中国怎么样不知道,
那么anyway我觉得大概率在声明上还是会发的,
这个是大概率还是会发的,虽然他第一天没有发,
但是他可能未必会,这个是我对川普的一个理解,他是来捞钱的,
所以他未必会真的很好的实施这个政策,但是他喊一口这个概率是很大的,
或者他某些方面他要在那个给中国上税,他概率很大,
他可能在技术方面,或者中国那个技术出口方面他可能会放一点,
但是在那个在这些中国最最核心的就是最打到中国最痛的地方他会给你放一点,
但是钱他是要收你的,所以就是这个关税政策对中国大概率还是会出现,
那么出现之后,CNH其实还没有完成定价,CNH完成就人民币完成定价的话,
我觉得在4.7到4.5,那么这个会有个ripple fact,
就是那个会有个叫什么ripple就是那个波动的波动的影响,
那么这个影响也会影响到其他的货币,
就再加上德国最近选举,德国选举之之前或者是德国选举之前,
我觉得那个德国的财政spending会明显的增加,
然后那个会打破财政spending,
今年那个欧洲都会用财政政策去追赶他的那个经济衰退,
或者是经济可能的拽退,
所以在这一系列的东西中间的日元很难独善的,
就说日元虽然相对欧元可能会好一点,相对人民币可能会好一点,
但是日元这个东西毕竟还是我觉得就是偏对美元来说还有可能会偏弱,
那么比欧阶这次战加息,
未必能够改变多少东西,
然后大家其实都已经预期定价了,
那么只要美元长期率率的波动是那么大,
它长期率率一直维持在变高的,相对高的位置,
那么counter trade还是make sense,
那个JGB不是1.6网,
就算你升到1.6,
那个10年期人家还在4.35,
就算最低跌到4.35,4.3,
人家还在一个比较高的位置,
所以这个是我对base case的一个基本的分析,
就大致我们分析一下base case,
那么我说一下特朗普,
另外还有最后再说几个交易的那个目标,
那个交易目标上的第一个就是,
我们现在看到在credit market上,
整个对于信贷的定价现在太紧了,
美国还有定在260个basis point,
就是还有债券的credit spread,
定在260个basis point,
我们会觉得其实在包括在credit上面,
定价也高,
credit的定价和股票定价都相对比较高,
利率呢在这个水平上,
那个是一个就是不会降太多的,
所以今年的alpha在哪里,
那我我我看了一下,
今年alpha可能会在agency bound,
就是fadingmate,fadingmac发那些债,
那些债basis IG,
就是比上那个美国投资级的债券,
可能有个200的basis point的差价,
所以在这里面呢就是,
agency bound本质的它的风险是没有的,
它跟那个美国国债的其实理论风险是一样的,
那为什么中间会有这个差价呢,
其实是买价的问题,
然后再加上这些agency,
其实agency bound很多的这个可买的人比较少,
它定价东西可买人比较少,
所以呢这个一直是有个差价在那,
但是你要long and hold,
买入持有,
我比方说你当成这个债券买入持有,
那么agency bound的这个可能,
它就是买的这个,
就是你的prime会更高一点,
那么相对国债,
相对agency,
就是投资级的这些债券会更好一点,
那么最后说一下trump policy,
那个特朗普的政策,
如果有时间我会,
还会简单再说一下那个,
英伟达这些,
那么特朗普呢,
在他上台之前去发了一个密密币,
在链上发了一个密密币,
这个行为其实是非常不好,
因为谁买你的密密币,
其实不太清楚的,
那个你去发一个,
现在变成600亿了已经,
那个,
当然600亿又跌下来,
现在可能是,
我最近没有看300亿吧,
就现在早上可能是300亿,
那么这个trump b发了以后,
其实变成了一个相伙钱,
你任何人如果说,
要给特朗普送钱,
那你其实只要去买一下trump b就好了,
那个trump b发这个 b的时候,
大部分的钱包都是从ok和gate,
然后来提的 b,
那都是中国,
不知道哪里来的人提的 b,
对吧,
然后在链上发完以后呢,
把它,
把它冲上线,
然后瞬间在所有交易所上市,
那trump发完 b 之后,
他的老婆Melinda,
也跟着要去发,
说他的儿子也要发 b,
所以,
这个背后,
我觉得,
就是发 b 这件事情,
其实主要影响是b 权,
那么,
我觉得在 b 权的影响,
可能就是,
原来大部分95 的钱,
都在中心化交易所,
这一把,
他们等于是,
把链上,
把它炒高了,
到中心化交易所来抛线,
那中心化交易所,
原来 bn 上币,
你要说你活筹,
要说你活筹,
所有活筹的70%,
说你整个盘的30%,
就等于上市的股票,
股东全是交易所,
但是这个不可能,
trump b 不可能,
所以,
被迫上市以后,
等于是用链上,
去割了这个,
中心化交易所,
把钱打到链上去,
所以,
未来几个月,
可能索罗娜这些链,
不用几个月吧,
未来几个星期,
这 b 权很快,
可能索罗娜这些链上,
这活跃度会很高,
他们都很有钱,
然后到处瞎冲,
我觉得,
这个概率会蛮大的,
但是,
一个更大的影响是,
trump 这家来干嘛的,
所以,
他们可能对于,
那个钱,
对于盈利,
就是对于捞钱,
这件事情,
还是挺热状的,
也就是说穿了,
特朗普,
这个人,
本身是个网红,
他是个败家子,
他把,
他把他爸爸,
70年代,
给了他7亿美元,
给败完了,
他做生意没有成功过,
就因为败完了以后,
他最后去看那个,
去做那个TV秀,
然后把钱给赚回来,
所以,
他本质上,
就是个网红,
所以,
你用从这个角度,
来看他的话,
他并不是一个成功商人,
那他网红,
想要生意,
正常,
那,
如果是这样的情况下,
他的政策的倾斜度,
对中国,
就不一定会这么严,
包括,
他在上台之前,
其实发过一个推特,
说我和习近平,
我和那个中国,
主席习近平,
经过了一个很好的交谈,
然后一起保证,
什么世界安全,
不达不达,
他邀请了,
很多人,
参加他的,
就是典礼,
那,
中间,
有韩正,
然后,
但是,
中间,
这个呢,
其实代表了很多,
那个台南帮都没去,
那,
这个中间,
代表了很多的,
这个他的态度,
就是他这个人,
嗯,
心眼并不是很大的,
呃,
他的敌人的朋友,
就是他的敌人,
他的敌人的敌人,
就是他的朋友,
那,
他的敌人是谁,
是democrats,
是民主党,
所以,
这个是他的世界观,
这个会影响到,
后面,
很多他全球,
视角上的,
这些政策,
包括他对乌克兰政策,
他对台湾的政策,
包括他对中国的政策,
就是,
他一方面,
可能是要钱的,
第二方面的,
他的这个,
呃,
屁股并不是坐在美国,
坐在他自己椅子上的,
那,
呃,
这个,
我说多了这个政治的东西,
但是,
呃,
影响是什么,
这个我个人的猜测,
因为我本来是,
没有,
对他这么反抗,
我甚至有段时间,
还是支持床,
那现在,
呃,
他改变我三关了,
所以,
他的三方面的政策,
会怎么样?
就是,
第一方面的,
他这个政策是,
deregulation,
去监管,
energy,
因为石油,
这些,
然后移民,
就是他所谓的安全,
然后关税,
关税对中国,
会不会发,
因为,
一定会发,
第一个要,
关税可以成中国人,
要钱,
第二个关税可以,
要钱到中国,
拿到更多的好处,
比方说,
把这套可以卖出来,
那么,
在关税的时候,
他会宣布,
但是呢,
不一定会非常严格的,
这些,
或者他宣布的,
就是,
雷神大,
会有一点小一点,
那我就,
我觉得,
这个是他对中国的,
一个态度,
对于欧洲的关税,
可能性不知道,
因为,
这东西呢,
还是会影响到经济的,
也就是说,
他包括,
原来,
很有理想的话,
他要搞Deregulation,
要把那个,
财政制治权,
剪掉,
那,
他要搞Deregulation,
但是,
做这些事情,
对经济都是有影响,
包括大规模驱逐移民,
都是有影响,
那,
他可能,
更在乎的是,
网红,
就是说,
我干了什么,
大家觉得我多厉害,
而不是,
真的要去做很多的事,
那,
这,
这有,
有这样的一个可能,
那,
如果是这样的话呢,
那个,
呃,
对中国可能,
会是,
实际上呢,
会有一个偏的利好,
就是在,
呃,
真正的事情,
然后,
那么,
这段时间,
可能是一个最会外的时候,
但是,
最后的时刻,
和中国的关系,
和中国的合作,
他会继续,
五歌唱,
五抓跳,
歌招唱,
这个可能很大,
然后,
在Deregulation上面,
或者是,
在第一,
DOG,
就是那个,
就,
减少政府赤字上面,
他会变得,
更加谨慎一些,
他也不想影响经济,
来捞钱的人,
都不希望,
股市跌太多的,
所以呢,
他未必会影响经济,
现在市场上,
我们讲到,
就像,
包括我在,
做交易的时候,
我也会看,
现在,
主线,
是我们刚刚讲的,
美国经济很好,
然后,
有个黑天鹅,
tell risk,
就是,
川普,
你到底要搞什么名堂,
会搞出什么事情,
那么,
在,
这个,
川普的这个,
黑天鹅的概率,
我觉得,
如果他是这样一个立场的话,
那么,
就会减少很多,
相对来说,
会减少很多,
其实,
是一个巨人的钱,
那不可能,
但是,
川普的态度,
那更加重要,
那个,
将,
另外呢,
就是energy,
energy,
它会第一时间,
发出东西出来,
因为,
这东西,
是不影响经济的,
它也不影响,
跟盟友的关系,
它也不会,
让它,
造成它的,
没有负面的,
就是,
比方说,
退出巴黎协定,
它好像今天早上,
已经退出了,
包括那个offshore,
就是offshore的石油开采,
就是那个,
它全给你取消掉,
那这个肯定是,
只有,
在经济上,
和只有正面,
没有负面,
那,
这些东西,
它就会第一时间去做,
甚至我觉得,
边境管理,
也未必会这么严,
就是,
这个人呢,
如果是你认清,
他是个网红本质,
他未必会那么严,
那,
边境管理上面,
deportation,
是最最,
就是,
把人驱逐出去,
这个是最最核心,
就是,
它人怎么进来,
还有,
就把它赶走,
赶走是减少劳动力的,
它以前说,
我要把它们都赶走,
然后,
但是呢,
有可能,
第一呢,
它也未必有那么多钱,
那个,
财政预算,
不还没批,
你要deportation,
得要钱的,
这个钱,
可能还没到位,
第二呢,
就是,
它,
呃,
身边有两帮人,
第一帮,
Second Valley,
有那个,
硅谷的帮精英,
另外一帮呢,
是那个,
马卡,
就是非常希望,
把他们钱,
所以这个呢,
也是,
呃,
有可能,
会有,
有变数的,
所以特朗普政策呢,
我感觉,
呃,
他如果全实施,
那,
真的实施,
他确实是黑天鹅,
可能会造成黑天鹅,
但是这个概率,
在下降,
也就是,
呃,
特朗普可能会在,
好的事情,
对经济好的事情上面,
采取更多的行动,
比方说,
energy,
能源,
石油,
那么在一些,
呃,
采取,
口头很强硬,
马上很快,
一个月到两个月出政策,
但是,
实事上呢,
缓一缓,
跟中国人继续谈,
获取更多的好处,
呃,
对于欧洲的这些政策呢,
可能会,
着重在某一些方面,
让他可以去吹,
就,
不要说汽车,
他可以加个水,
但是,
整体,
用Riversal Tax,
不一定会加,
或者是,
加的幅度不太清楚,
那么在那个,
呃,
去监管,
很多事情,
让他立马给你搞,
在外交上,
就是,
谁是我的朋友,
谁是我的敌人,
比较倒霉的时候,
乌克兰克台湾,
所以,
这个,
可能,
有可能,
比较倒霉的时候,
乌克兰克台湾,
呃,
那么最后,
我说一下,
这个,
股票的那些,
公司的盈利,
或者公司的情况,
因为,
最近,
很多人也在,
讨论那个Villian,
Villian说他那个,
Covas S,
Covas L,
的这个现成的问题,
就是说,
简单来说,
Covas S,
那么,
是做H芯片的,
被捡了很多,
捡了80%,
这个其实,
一两个月前的消息吧,
然后呢,
Covas L,
可能还没跟上,
就B100,
有很多很多的问题吧,
B100不是,
他在做他的这个,
服务器的时候,
出了很多问题,
那包括,
封装啊,
包括Rock Level的,
这个协同啊,
这都有一些问题,
所以,
大家可能比较担心,
就是,
因为大家后面的盈利,
那么,
因为大家盈利,
担心以后呢,
就担心,
Microsoft,
担心Google,
我个人觉得呢,
是这样,
我对英伟达盈利,
我觉得,
不用担心,
我得到的消息是,
呃,
包括台积电,
他们也出来说的是,
就是,
呃,
英伟达这次的盈利,
不会有问题,
甚至我觉得,
英伟达今年盈利,
都没有问题,
但是英伟达这个票呢,
呃,
如果投资的话呢,
在3月份,
到6月份之间,
我是会跑掉的,
呃,
本质的原因是,
这个问题,
不,
不存在于今年,
今年,
基本上,
它的业绩是确定的,
但是呢,
明年的业绩是不确定的,
也就是说,
当我们去年,
在超级英伟达去,
在时候,
比方说90块钱,
那是无脑买,
因为我记得到,
他,
记得到他今年,
一定是5块钱以上,
那么,
20倍批又100,
30倍批就150,
对吧,
但是,
明年有多少,
不清楚,
因为,
整个市场,
包括,
都需要做一个证明,
就是证明,
AI这个东西的,
实际应用,
用得起来了,
现在,
英伟达这个问题,
他是自己不能回答的,
他,
他这个问题说,
整个市场帮他就回答,
所以,
明年你能卖多少,
26年是不是能继续,
这个本质的问题是,
Enterprise,
企业端,
应用AI,
是不是会尝试,
会尝试多少,
那么,
包括,
我们现在看到,
云糖生意这么好,
因为大家要去尝试AI,
比方说,
我要去调用它,
我先要把这个数据,
全部搬到,
那个Amazon,
或者是AWS,
或者是,
搬到那个Microsoft,
上面去,
这一波他完成了,
后面还会继续,
但是调用的,
就AI的这些调用会怎么样,
所以,
这个问题,
确实市场很难回答,
也就是说,
我们能够,
我上次,
跟很多朋友说到,
我们能够去赌,
英伟达今年盈利没有问题,
但是,
你不要去赌,
它的那个,
26年盈利怎么样,
所以恰恰,
我觉得,
并不是这一个基督,
你要去跑掉,
去躲它盈利的雷,
觉得年底很好,
应该是觉得,
年底很好,
你要在现在,
就觉得,
现在是可以拿,
但是到了年中的时候,
要先讨,
要看看,
最后的AI的情况,
怎么,
因为一旦,
AI的应用,
真的没有起来的话,
那么导致的影响,
并不是一个伟大一家,
所有人都要党媒的,
就是,
包括,
大的云场,
包括前端的应用,
那AI如果没有起来,
我个人是比较,
偏看好的,
AI的应用会出了,
那么多的那个公司,
在做AI的这个,
Consultant,
在IBM,
在那个,
这个,
这些,
资讯公司,
做那么多的Consultant,
然后呢,
重新要去投入,
这个,
他一定会尝试,
领导艺的尝试,
我觉得一定会发生的,
大概率是会发生的,
但是如果不发生,
那么这个影响,
就会非常不明,
现在Microsoft的对于,
英伟来的芯片,
是采取这样的态度,
他,
72不是有一些问题吗?
那36,
也可能也有点问题,
但是,
Microsoft的愿意在大规模,
完成测试之前,
直接去下单,
因为他要尽快的建立,
他的这个,
算力的产能,
而且吧,
就是四季度的,
那个,
像Microsoft的盈利,
更多的影响的因素,
应该是,
六个月以前,
也就是,
现在是11月份了,
就是四季度,
就是12月份,
就六月份了,
那个时候没有产能问题,
或者是那个时候,
产能,
新一波产能刚出来,
所以,
相,
相反,
我是觉得,
四季度和一季度,
像这些,
呃,
MSFT,
Oracle,
就是,
财报面识,
就接下去的,
财报面识的概率不胜的,
就我相对来说,
更看好,
那么现在有很多的,
就是,
Argue,
就是有很多的,
各种各样小作吧,
英伟拿出来的这些小作,
你可以全部不用看,
对,
就就就,
不对的,
那么,
关注的是一个,
更长期的趋势,
所以,
呃,
我还是对这个,
像,
特别是对Navillion这个票,
我是觉得,
就是,
你在第一季度,
现在不是第一季,
现在是四季度,
第一季度的财报出来左右,
那这个时候,
是一个,
需要走掉的时候,
或者是需要,
我,
完全去review,
你这个头寸的时候,
所以这个,
我今天就,
囊括这些,
这些信息吧,
呃,
看看大家这边,
有些什么问题,
嗯,